want to go now to senate majority leader
chuck schumer senator thank you for
being here good morning i think it's a
sign of the health of our republic that
those images we just saw still have the
capacity to shock us oh i was there i
was within 30 feet
of these rioters i got to the floor of
the senate at 1pm my first time as
putative majority leader because early
that morning we had learned we had won
the two seats in georgia i hadn't even
given a speech when a capitol hill
police officer
the bulletproof vest submachine gun
across his waist grabs me by the collar
like this i'll never forget it says
senator we're in danger
we walk out of the chamber we walk
through a door
and we're in within 20 feet of those
riders had one of them had a gun had two
of them blocked off the door lord knows
what would have happened one of them was
reported to say there's the big jew
let's get him bigotry against one is
bigotry against all well senator let's
talk about danger one year later a
majority of americans think that that
was not a singular event but a mark of a
new era where there will be more
violence in this country do you share
that fear i do share that fear you know
when there there's a mob
when democracy is a danger it often
starts with a mob and not everyone is
part of the mob but people excuse the
mob people egg on the mob donald trump
is still doing that and we're seeing
violence still right now are threats of
violence against election brokers poll
workers across the country
and too many people excuse the mob
follow the mob this is how democracy has
eroded history has shown us donald trump
has blame you know we had some great
moments that day when we went to that
secret place mcconnell mccarthy pelosi
and i said we're going to come back at 8
pm and count the votes but that moments
of courage and outrage by mcconnell and
mccarthy are gone they're following
trump they are they are gone the message
has changed from the republican party
something that also has happened on the
republican side of the aisle is you have
more than a dozen states that have
in their view secured elections election
integrity in the view of your side
suppress the vote you want to change
that by passing a voting rights bill
what's your plan to get that done and do
you fear doing so could actually deepen
the polarization that got us here if
when people are eroding democracy
they're not aiming uh the first there's
no evidence of fraud none and yet they
pursue it said that donald trump's
department of homeland security has said
that yeah
and it's who's it aimed at people of
color young people college campuses poor
people urban people all democratic
voters they're trying to jaundice the
elections so they're never fair again we
cannot allow that in a democracy so on
the 17th mlk day i will put on the floor
two bills that will allow the justice
department to come in and undo these
restrictive votings that are reminiscent
of jim crow
and if we have to change the rules to do
it we will have to vote on changing
those rules we don't have all the votes
for that yet but we're fighting every
day to get them senator i was in
washington dc on 9 11 and i remember the
aftermath of that terrible day was one
where we came together as a country in
the aftermath of this terrible day we
have anything drifted further apart how
do you change that can a politician
change that well we try and you got to
speak truth it's truth to power and i
just would pray to so many americans who
may have a different ideology than i
have and democrats have not to follow
donald trump
donald trump is spreading the big lie he
is sowing mistrust in this democracy
already two-thirds of republicans
believe that big lie if we do
if we allow these legislatures to undo
things so unfairly the rest of the
country may not believe in our democracy
and then where are we if we don't
believe in the integrity of our
elections
what happens to our democracy so i am
worried i am worried to worry i share
when you look at the polls though the
the doubts in our system exist on both
sides of the aisle right and
polarization uh
is not we don't come to this place uh
with equal blame but it does take two to
get here i am eager to work with
republicans and to work with the other
side to restore our democracy how do you
do that well the problem is so far just
about every one of them is so afraid of
donald trump even when they whisper to
us
that they
don't like what he's saying don't agree
with he's saying they're afraid to
resist him he has a power over the
republican party right now that is
damaging i am hopeful that brave voices
like liz cheney like kinzinger in the
house that they will multiply and speak
up because the republican party in the
past has always been for voting rights
the two bushes were for voting rights
reagan was for voting rights you cannot
take away people's rights to vote in the
horrible and crass ways they're doing it
and expect our democracy to keep going
but senator you're blaming republican
elected officials yes is the blame
really with them or is it with the
voters who they're responding to well
the republican officials have a
responsibility to lead some of the
voters go along with the republicans
some don't but people should realize
when
you don't stand up
to the violence of a mob
and the lies that a leader is spreading
democracy could erode so we hope and
pray
that more and more republicans the
number of people who think donald trump
to blame on the republican side is
increasing not by enough yet but
increasing and he he is he
this man this man who
he's such a he's such an egotist he
can't accept that he lost the election
fairly and squarely and instead he's
eroding our democracy
senator i appreciate you being here with
us one year later as we start to
hopefully build the democracy back up
again we need to do that and i'm
pleading with republican
voters republican people across the
country do not follow the big lie your
ideology doesn't have to be the same as
ours we can disagree respectfully but we
cannot follow a big lie all right
senator the conversation will continue
thank you indeed thank you uh nate and
gail as i send it back to you in new
york i think it's important to remember
that we did do this to ourselves we have
it within ourselves to fix it but it's
up to us only we can do it guys
no doubt he said something that was
powerful we can disagree respectfully
tony will be with us from the capitol
all morning long as we reflect on that
day